it is great to be joined today by
Charles Eisenstein who's a noted
activists thinker and author his latest
book is climate a new story Charles it's
so great to talk to you I really
appreciate it yeah thanks for having me
on so to start with if you were to say
to me hey I've identified some problems
in how the left is dealing with climate
change I would kind of have two
different areas I would want to sort of
think about one of those areas would be
are those who believe the climate
science doing the wrong things in order
to try to mitigate the problem but then
the other side of it is is the way that
the issue is being communicated part of
the problem in terms of getting more
people to understand the reality of
what's going on let's maybe start there
are both of these issues is one more of
an issue than the other I think that
they are both issues and that they are
related to each other so the way that
the problem is being addressed and
considered on a policy level has some of
the same problems that the way that it's
being rejected that's being addressed on
a rhetorical level so the other book
related it so maybe we'll start with the
messaging part and then that will lead
us to maybe how the policy part is not
actually the the right approach so first
in terms of messaging what do you
identify that is being done incorrectly
by those who believe the science want to
deal with this issue but where are they
going wrong on the messaging well
there's a few a few levels of that I
think on a very basic level the
messaging that the essential messaging
that answers well why should we do
anything about the problem and answers
that if we don't bad things will happen
to us I think that invoking a fear
mentality that looks at nature for it's
for what it does for us that's part of
the problem to say they say well why
should we care about the rest of life
why should we care about the world
because bad things will happen to us
that denies that
that the rainforests the whales the
coral reefs the the soil the water has
inherent value in its own right and so
it contributes to the instrumentalizing
and distancing of nature that I think is
at the root of the problem to begin with
okay so let's deal with that in more
detail I agree with you my question is
at this point if you still either deny
the science or are uncaring about it or
whatever are you going to be more likely
to say wow we really do need to take
action now if we talk about the reefs
and other animals in other words aren't
these people already haven't they
already demonstrated they don't care
about that well I think that the people
who don't believe climate science and
and the general narrative of climate
change are adopting that partly as part
of a political identity that goes way
beyond climate change so if you are you
know a trump supporter and identify
generally with conservative political
beliefs then you're gonna be predisposed
to reject the climate narrative yes this
time you might really care about your
your local forests and streams and you
might not want to have your groundwater
your water table polluted with fracking
fluid and you might have places where
you love to hunt and fish
so by Framing it is primarily in terms
of this politicized global issue
sometimes we risk eliminating potential
allies who might really care about
localized ecocide and that leads to the
other part of my thesis which is that
localized ecocide is much more important
than then the carbon reductionist
narrative understands okay so in one
sense I mean I think part of what you're
saying is and correct me if I'm wrong
that when you hear about global ocean
temperature's going up by X amount or
these sort of very
at level figures that on the one hand
that can be hard to kind of understand
intellectually in terms of what it means
or it might not even sound like that
much what's one degree Celsius anyway
but that it also kind of misses the ways
in which individual and local
communities will also be affected is
that part of it making it local yeah so
like I was I'm in Rhode Island I'm here
with my wife where we where she grew up
and you know we're down on the in the
Narragansett Beach area she's like wow
that used to be a clamming beach right
there you know and these tidal pools
they used to have seein enemies and they
stabbed all kinds at least to see eels
in this estuary here and like all that
is gone and the seagrass Meadows like
eighty percent of them are gone from New
England and so people like there's like
she could talk to anybody around here
and they'd be like yeah that that that's
really too bad whether or not they
whatever their political orientation and
what we're what I'm seeing is that um
these are not only local issues like
seagrass Meadows for example sequester
enormous amounts of carbon kelp forests
with with lively with with robust
shellfish populations they sequester a
lot of carbon so even from a carbon
narrative I mean not to mention wetlands
forests and so forth ecosystems
contribute immensely to planetary
homeostasis and and climate equilibrium
and that's only thinking about carbon if
you go to the water cycle the
contribution toward climate stability of
ecosystems is even greater so it's kind
of like this you know do you care about
the local or do you care about the the
greenhouse gas levels it's kind of a
false dichotomy and and we've made that
a false dichotomy with the to some
extent at least with the polarizing
rhetoric and political positioning
around it that I think is not necessary
or ideal so let's let's take some of
those ideas and take them to the next
level let's assume we're dealing with
folks who
understand what you're saying about both
the local and and the planet-wide level
who either with more math or less math
understand what's going on and sort of
accept it then we often hear okay listen
I think that the free markets going to
solve it I think that science and
technology and industry will always be a
step ahead because their livelihood
depends on it if the stuff that you say
is going to happen happens all these
businesses literally will go out of
business I think that that has already
demonstrably failed and that's the
approach I usually take but how would
you deal with someone who tries to make
that case that it's all going to be
sorted out yeah there's two levels of
problem with that one well three one of
which is that it hasn't worked as you
point out secondly that in order for
markets to take ecological health
well-being into account the it has to be
monetized somehow so there has to be
some kind of metrics through which the
ecological costs can be internalized
onto the balance sheet so something like
the carbon tax or pollution taxes or
some kind of quota system for natural
resources things like that make
pollution expensive or emissions
expensive and so theoretically then you
could invoke market mechanisms to
incentivize pro-environmental behavior
but that leads to an even deeper level
of the problem which is that it assumes
that ecological health can be quantified
but what happens is when we try that we
end up quantifying only the things that
we are able to measure or that we think
are important or that
can be measured and it's one of the deep
conceits of our civilization that that
this is possible that we can some day
encompass the entire world in a set of
data but ordinarily usually what happens
when you try that is that the things
that we don't see
left out which actually then turn out to
be really important and and that the
metrics used encode the interests of the
people and institutions that have
created the metrics so you know what
gets left out who gets left out
something always gets left out like if
you're wanting to monetize Carbon
somehow then emissions are quite easy to
quantify above-ground biomass is sort of
easy to quantify below ground biomass
not so easy and what about the carbon
contribution of a whale what's that if
you if you use the obvious metrics it's
it's very close to zero but when you
understand that plummeting whale
populations deprived the orcas of food
so that they turn on the seals and the
sea otters and eat them which then no
longer keep the sea urchins in check
which then proliferate and destroy the
kelp forests which no longer feed the
shellfish which sequester carbon like
yeah and you're like oh I guess the
whales were pretty important after all
too bad we didn't include them in our
metrics so so I think that we need to
move beyond a metrics centred approach
to ecological health and therefore also
beyond just a market centred approach
yeah that's uh that's extraordinarily
depressing of an example it will
resonate with our audience okay since we
don't have unlimited time I want to
focus a little bit on in terms of the
policy and what which should actually be
done in the immediate like now through
the next five years what are the actual
low-hanging fruit and sort of like must
dues that the pro environment community
should be calling for and focusing on
yeah so number one priority is
conservation of all remaining pristine
ecosystems especially the amazon the
congo wetlands forests because these are
key organs of the living being called
gaia that maintain its health and the
reservoirs of biodiversity and the
memory of healthy life on this planet
second priority is regeneration
regenerative agriculture
the soil healing water a reforestation
at forestation to again strengthen the
organs of a living being that's my whole
approach is that earth is alive and then
thirdly on the tissue level to use this
metaphor to to really change the
repeated dousing of the entire biosphere
with chemicals so if we do all these
things conservation and regeneration
that also necessarily includes a vast
reduction in fossil fuel production and
strip mining it's not just the fuels but
but if we were really going to take
seriously to love and care for a living
being
then greenhouse gases are going to have
to fall also so and along those lines
Charles I am getting more and more
inquiries from self-described
environmentalists who ask is the idea of
more nuclear as a bridge to getting off
of fossil fuels something to be taken
seriously where do you fall on that yeah
if you are in the mindset of carbon
reductionism like like equating green
with low carbon then it's pretty hard to
argue against nuclear power I mean you
know there are arguments against it but
but you know it does produce a lot less
emissions than traditional fossil fuel
generation of power but when you look at
a ecosystem living planet view then you
don't want to mess with that stuff
because the damage that the waste and
the potential accidents can cause is is
so horrifying that it's just
inconceivable from a living planet view
that you would use nuclear power so so
in the immediate then what do we now
replace fossil fuel generated energy
with because we can have somewhat of a
reduction maybe in the amount of energy
that that we're producing but we know
that getting people to actually reduce
consumption is a big project in and of
itself in the short-term how do you
start moving off of the fossil fuels and
exactly what do you move to in the
immediate yeah I mean I don't think that
there are any great solutions I mean out
of everything I like rooftop solar for
the best but even more than that is is
conservation and in the if you want to
like take carbon out of the atmosphere
the fastest way to do that
besides disarmament and and you know
dismantling the military industrial
complex the fastest way to do that is
through regenerative agriculture because
soil can absorb enormous amounts of
carbon very very quickly
we learned in school that it takes 500
years to build an inch of topsoil but
there are people out there like like
Ernst gosh in Brazil and Gabe brown and
is it North Dakota or South Dakota
somewhere out there like they're
building an inch a year okay topsoil if
everybody if we did that on a mass scale
it would it would quickly draw down
atmospheric carbon that's I think if if
we're gonna focus on carbon that's what
we should do because also of the side
benefits of repairing the water cycle -
I can go deep deep into the water cycle
but I am aware that we don't have a
whole lot of time well that that in fact
is is all of our time I do want to tell
people that the book is absolutely
fascinating we've been talking with
Charles Eisenstein who is the author of
climate a new story we've only barely
scratched the surface of what he has in
the book and Charles I really appreciate
you joining me today to talk about this
yeah I really enjoyed it as well thank
you so much